it's all over for Uranus
the ice giant is locked into a collision
course with the king of all planets in
our solar system Jupiter
what would happen as the two planets
made their epic approach
would Uranus get pulled apart into bits
and pieces
or could this ice giant somehow deal a
mortal blow to its gigantic opponent
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter and Uranus collided
okay let's get to know our two planetary
prize Fighters a little better
you know before they both potentially
get blown into Oblivion
first Jupiter the largest planet in the
solar system put all the other planets
together and it's still twice as massive
but this monstrosity has no solid
surface it's nearly all gas mostly made
out of hydrogen and helium
in the other corner of the ring is
Uranus
even though it's three times smaller and
20 times less massive than Jupiter it's
the third largest planet in the solar
system so don't let the size difference
fool you underneath Uranus's hydrogen
and helium atmosphere there's an
abundance of Water Ice
that's why Uranus isn't a gas giant like
Jupiter it's an ice giant like its
neighbor Neptune
of all the planets in the solar system
Uranus is unique it rotates on its side
all thanks to an earth-sized object that
slammed into it billions of years ago
so could the most epic Collision in the
history of collisions end with Uranus
getting knocked right side up
before we witness this epic disaster
unfold let's take a minute to thank our
sponsor Henson shaving look shaving is a
part of our everyday lives but these
little plastic razors have a massive
impact on our environment I used to go
through a few dozen of these razors a
year
a lot of us do but all that plastic
waste goes from your bathroom to the
landfill where it sits for decades
unable to break down polluting our
planet even more
but with Henson shaving I'm reducing my
carbon footprint and getting the best
shave of my life
Henson's perfectly balanced al-13 razor
supports the blade right at the edge
giving me a smooth shave and keeping my
lines tight the double-edged blades are
plastic free so when you need to change
them out you just pop them in the
recycle bin and check out this razor
it's made to Aerospace standards yeah
Henson used to manufacture Aerospace
Parts they even helped build parts of
the Mars rover and now all that craft
and Care is being put into this razor
the last razor you may ever buy
so where can you get yours go to
hensonshaving.com and enter what if at
checkout to get 100 free blades with the
purchase of the al-13 just pick your
favorite color for the razor add the 100
blade pack and enter the code at
checkout
Henson razors are built to last a
lifetime but if these planets Collide
that promise might be cut short
you likely don't track Uranus's
whereabouts in the night sky but if you
did you'd be in for the realization that
the icy planet has somehow slipped out
of its usual orbit commencing countdown
to Collision
on its way toward Jupiter Uranus would
first need to survive a close encounter
with the gas giant next door Saturn
with all its colorful rings and many
moons Saturn is twice as large as the
stinky Blue Planet
but the two planets have very similar
gravitational pulls so as they just
barely brush past one another Well
Uranus could end up sweeping up a moon
or two to add to its current collection
of 27.
Uranus would now be barreling down onto
its opponent
the closer it gets the clearer the
picture would become of just how
incredibly enormous that opponent is
Jupiter is over 20 times as massive as
Uranus and even though it doesn't
technically have a surface its surface
gravity is more than twice as strong
maybe Uranus was barking up the wrong
planetary tree
except it's too late to turn back now
besides you've got front row seats to
this epic fight
it wouldn't be smooth sailing right up
into Jupiter's atmosphere
first Uranus would have to Elbow its way
through some of Jupiter's 80 moons
the first of these would be pacify
there wouldn't be too much to worry
about here pacify is very small it's
more than 60 times smaller than our moon
Uranus would pass right by it and the
remaining Minefield of Jupiter's moons
completely unscathed
[Music]
okay now the planetary heavyweights
would be getting close
but how this Collision would unfold
would all depend on Uranus's angle of
impact
if it somehow managed to slip into
Jupiter's orbit then the two would be on
course for a head-on collision
in this event the atmospheres of both
planets would compress as they came into
contact
this would result in both of their
temperatures rapidly increasing and then
boom
no no I'm just kidding with no oxygen on
either Planet they wouldn't ignite in
fiery explosions
but if you're only in it for the
spectacle well don't worry the Collision
would still be very violent
the two planets would make full body
contact combining their Mass along the
way like a Uranus or a maybe a Jupiter
one thing that wouldn't happen though is
Jupiter turning into a star
in order to become a brown dwarf it
would need to weigh 13 times more than
it does now or 85 times more if it
wanted to become a low mass star
sadly adding Uranus under its belt would
only increase Jupiter's mass by a
fraction
now more realistically Uranus would hit
Jupiter from the side
this Collision would also begin with the
two atmospheres compressing except
instead of merging into one they'd both
remain somewhat intact but have a lot of
their gases thrown off into space
so after this epic encounter we'd still
be left with eight planets in the solar
system though these two would certainly
look a little different Jupiter would
look like a thinner version of its
formerly huge gassy self
and Uranus could end up being not much
more than a solid Rocky core covered in
water and ammonia if things unfolded
like this then that could leave Saturn
to take over the Throne of largest
planet in the solar system
well that makes me think what would
happen if the two gas giants collided in
all their former glory
[Music]
well that's a story for another
what if
foreign